yeah well it's probably Jim farm no
that's actually the eggs if I farted I
tell you it was the eggs and maybe some
farts earlier it is the egg smell you
know it wasn't a guess of this morning
down good to see you around probably not
the way I should have come in hi guys I
appreciate the honesty I don't like it
when guests come in here and they act
like they don't smell farts the huge
stink yeah the studio never smells good
it's really off-putting for guests and
everybody like ignores it there you go
Hollywood on us yeah that was new you
get the straight scoop from this genuine
article so you're uh we had my companion
was it yesterday or two days ago well
it's also talking about this he's
awesome yeah he is who do you play in
this I played colonel max Bowers who was
the commanding officer of 3rd battalion
5th Special Forces Group
by the way 12 strong is what this is yes
yes it's about this group and
interesting story about that is the
story takes place in October of 2001 I
was attached to this unit in November of
2001 I was a captain at the time and I
reported directly to lieutenant-colonel
max Bowers who I now play in the movie
so I'm playing my old boss let's see you
basically say that did you like him uh
yeah I did I think you know I mean you
know as much as you like a boss yeah I
mean he was he was my boss he was but he
was good at his job he knew what he was
doing and he cared about his men so
that's pretty much all you can ask for
where was this and for November of 2001
if you're in the Marine Corps you're
over there yeah what were you doing in
the Marines over there and because I was
before technically Bush had the invasion
or any that stuff right well yeah we
were still I mean it was brand-new like
we're you know 9/11 just happened two
months prior to when I got there so I
was actually doing I was sent from
Central Command I was actually here in
New York actually on 9/11 pursuing
comedy and acting I was doing sketch and
improv down at The Upright Citizens
Brigade theater but I was in the
reserves at that time because I left
active duty in 2000 so on 9/11 my unit
is a reserve unit here in Manhattan
we're like the only reserve unit in
Manhattan so I was activated the night
of September 11th September 12th I
reported to Ground Zero and started
working on the rubble piles
moving buckets of rubble and the bucket
brigade is it a good excuse at all when
you're cleaning up after 9:00
eleven to tell people that you have to
go do your improv Scout a tight five
guys over the piano room no but I yeah
so I that's out so I got called back and
then but only for 30 days so at
September 30th my orders were over and
then but I volunteered to go back on
active duty Central Command picked me up
I had a high security clearance for my
job I had a green badge which is like
top secret with ask if clearance so not
many people had that erence it's like an
eyes-only type thing you know you get to
you get to go behind some doors that
some other people don't what job did you
have that you can add to get that and
what's the more with the job I was
Public Affairs civil affairs so I'm kind
of my my graduate degrees in public
administration working with
municipalities civic leaders hearts and
minds that kind of stuff working with
the media what love up like a ferris on
what level was above you that you
couldn't see like there had to be a guy
above you go there I have this level
clearance so you had a green badge you
said yeah what's a higher level than
that that you were not permitted to see
I I don't know there is clearly there is
but I don't know what it was that's how
high level it is even know what color
exactly that's exactly but know there
that there's definitely higher levels
clearly there's clearly higher levels
but I for my job I had a pretty high
level so I knew they were gonna need
people sure you know the point and I
knew that I had stuff that they would
need so I volunteered to go back on
active duty I was picked up November
10th November 17th I reported at Central
Command November 30th I was in
Afghanistan so like you get all this
education and you've also got all this
military experience do you ever have
these moments when you're doing like
total goofball stuff of like I know you
guys are all having a good time but you
know you know what my history is too you
know she don't have been thrown oh look
when you're when you're like on New
Year's Eve and you're in that like
silver suit or whatever and everyone's
like oh it's fun Rob Riggle are you ever
like yeah but you know what else I do
you yes no because those I it's weird
people always want to know how much
those streams cross and I never crossed
those streams ever I was their total
opposite ends of the spectrum to me so I
just wear different hats at different
times just you know yeah but anyway so I
ended up going over and serving with
this to this unit
and and so I'm playing my old boss now
what part of Afghanistan northern
Afghanistan I was in mazar-e-sharif
so in the night in the movie 12 strong
that's where the that's what they're
going to they're trying to get to
mazar-e-sharif to drive the Taliban out
of there so I got there shortly after
they had taken the city so did you talk
to local warlords to have heard stories
that they would actually get information
using Viagra where these guys had no
experience with what it would do and
they would be able to go home back and
[ __ ] their wives they would actually
talk to people when they had this
miracle yeah that was blue clearance
[Laughter]
yeah but I've heard that they would give
these guys like to get information like
what are you gonna give him that they
need there were three warlords in the
north okay there was MOA kata and doston
and and mossad was the guy who kind of
held all three warlords together and
fought the Taliban two days before 9/11
al Qaeda assassinated Mossad as payment
to the Taliban because Taliban wanted
you know the Northern Alliance out of
there so they did that they assassinated
Mossad on September 9th and then al
Qaeda attacked us on September 11th
so the Northern Alliance was fragile it
was it was about to dissolve and that's
when we joined him and we kept him
together long enough to fight the
Taliban and drive him out of northern
Afghanistan which gave us a foothold and
then we could push down south and take
over the rest but aren't they right back
in right now because those guys never
leave like they don't leave the country
so aren't they just kind of going back
into where they were like there's no way
it's almost like if you push water back
even as soon as you move it comes right
back in it's like digging a sand hole
yeah it came yeah yeah you know look
it's and the the allegiance over there
sometimes is not always guaranteed you
know they I think they tend to go where
the strength is if you're strong hey
we're on this side their bandwagon their
bandwagon jumpers you know like
everybody's jumping on the Patriots
bandwagon a lot right yeah right because
they're winners the same day yeah yeah
and you're like what are you compared to
the Past American team exactly exactly
so I don't know I you know I don't know
if they've what progress is being made I
haven't know
a long long time so they got this right
yeah so having you there probably helped
because you were there so you know but
got it right yeah the guys that are
being portrayed like well you had pinyin
in here right yeah okay so they had some
of the guys the Chris Hemsworth
character Michael Shannon's character
they were on set the whole time we're
making the movie so they were there to
give all kinds of great advice and and I
mean down to the smallest things if this
is how we hold our weapon this is how we
you know this is how we talked to one
another and so and the actors were very
serious about getting it right - so I
think it's a pretty accurate portrayal
of what happened when you've got a
reputation for comedy like and maybe
people don't know your history I mean
your co-stars might have but like do you
have to do you feel any need to prove to
like guys like Michael Pena and Michael
Michael Shannon who like have these kind
of amazing resumes that you're like no I
can do I can do this drunken support
dramatics and I've got a little bit of
life experience to go with it so well
look you I don't know if it's like you
want to prove anything to anybody yeah
you just want to do your best and
hopefully they appreciate it yeah I mean
you know like any human being you know
one looks like an ass you don't look
like a total fool so so yeah but I look
when I was in New York I studied acting
as well wasn't just improv and comedy or
whatever it was there was the whole
gamut of theatre and acting and so I
don't know I feel like I I've always
felt like I could do it you just show
business is tricky you don't get
opportunities you know if you play a
great funny douchebag
guess what kind of roles are gonna get
right sugar fun and ooshpa and if you're
that guy who's like I'm not doing any
more funny to do space like well then
there's no no roles the phone stops
ringing right yeah and you're like well
[ __ ] that sucks I said I got a mortgage
to pay yeah so yeah so I you ended up
playing a comedic douchebag Ilan which
is what I hello yeah so that's fine
don't get me wrong like I actually
enjoyed that I think it's a super funny
but but I was like I can do other things
if someone would just give me a chance
and so I was lucky enough to get a
couple opportunities the last year to do
some dramatic more dramatic stuff and
they'll come out this you I'm still
doing a comedy I'm doing a comedy with
Kevin Hart comes out in September so
that's a good guy to do a cop yeah yeah
you have a pilot's license you got from
when you were in college yeah yeah
that's how I actually kind of started in
the Marines I had my pilot's license
when I was an undergrad and I took a
test for the Marines and got a
guaranteed flight contract so I was a
theater and film major in college and I
also a pilot when I saw when you
graduate from university Kansas was a
theater and film major or any University
you're gonna be a waiter for a long time
or I could be tough gun and I figured
yeah Top Gun so you can mix out a little
better yeah there's a trade you're like
okay well I'm gonna learn how to fly
military grade that age you could fly
military jet like your instrument
qualified and all that this is amazing
yeah well I wasn't instrument qualified
I was VFR pilot single-engine in
undergrad but you know when I was look
like I went through I graduated I was 22
I was in flight school when I was 23 so
you know I was yeah I mean you're you're
you're young young person when you're
learning how to fly those things so when
you're studying acting and you're doing
comedy and you're flying planes and
stuff was there when you're a young man
like this is the dream like this is what
I wanted
no that's what I'm like I think all this
I got to a certain point in flight
school when I realized like I liked
flying but I didn't love it and all the
guys that were in my flight class loved
it
they've been dreaming about it since
they were kids and they would talk about
it we go out to the bars at night on a
Friday night after a long week of you
know studying and flying and I'd want to
have a couple beers and socialize and
they were over there in the corner
talking with their hands you know like
you know oh man I was doing this and
that it kind of like wow they can't even
let it go on the weekend I was like okay
and then I but then I was like what what
am i Pat what what is something that I
am passionate but I really really want
to do in a comedy and acting you know
comedies always it's just I don't know I
very passion about comedy I love it so I
realized I looked at my contract I was
like oh [ __ ] if I pin on these wings
they own me for eight years after I pin
on the wings so I've already been in
four to pin that on that's ten I'd only
have ten more years to retirement I'd be
foolish to get out at that point because
I'd be a senior captain or a junior
major probably so all the sudden I was
like holy [ __ ] I'm in 20 years how did
that happen right my life right and I'm
23 24 so I was like
so I said okay
I'm I'm not gonna finish flight school
I'm gonna transfer over to the ground
side it become a ground officer because
you know the commitment goes down from
eight years down quite a bit yeah and
that's what I did so I quit flying I
went over the ground side and ended up
but the funny thing is I still ended up
staying in for 23 years when you when
you are when you you're learning to fly
and you're doing all that stuff
do you press zero way they practice
eject this is he's an officer and
gentleman where they're trying to show
them the who the Red Hand David Caruso
who's so nervous he goes I is just to
hit with the force of the real planet
it's like son this is nothing compared
to it do they try to show you what it
feels like to be ejected oh yeah they
have that actually when you it's called
D jet qualifications and you have to go
through it before you can start flight
school it's part of the aviation and
Doctrine ation package that they have
and there's things this might just
stinks they won't fit they try to fix it
and it just my arm the arm sucks yeah
yeah so that and the what Caruso went
down and is called the Dilbert dunker
and what happened you slide down the
rails you hit and you go upside down
like that right yeah and then you you
have to unbuckle yourself and get
yourself out of the cockpit and get to
the surface and I did that I did that
you do it you do it with goggles and you
do it blind and you do it with sight so
they put you they put on like
blacked-out goggles so you can't see so
it simulates a nighttime crash Wow Wow
and you have to use your points so you
know you you hit you have one hand up on
here and you have to trace your arm all
the way back down here and find your
belt buckle right and that release is
the five-point harness and then once you
do that you go you have to go back up
and then you grab the top of the cockpit
and you pull yourself out and push
yourself up but you follow the air
bubbles cuz air bubbles always go up but
you get discombobulated under you do and
you're upside down right yeah and it's
in and the water's going up your nose
and it's going in your ears through your
helmet and it's very uncomfortable and
it's hard to do it's really it's a lahar
that you idiots it's uncomfortable
it's uncomfortable staying calm and
those situations is not the easiest
thing in the world you can't panic they
do yeah there was a couple people who
panic but they always have divers
underneath there and they'll let you you
know they watch you the whole time and
they can see like people bump there
heads on stuff like they get confused
about where they're at especially when
they're blacked out sure because the
protocol thing is really interesting
because your instincts lie to you right
yeah like so you this thing you're like
oh I think I should do this you're like
no I just enjoy the protocol feels wrong
in this moment yeah just gonna do
exactly what it was right you don't want
to trace your arm you probably just
reach down and it goes no trace the arm
right you do all that they teach you to
go by the numbers do all this stuff but
when you're upside down in water and you
feel like you're running out of air all
of that flies out of your brain and the
only thing you're thinking is get out
get out get out and that's when the
panic sets in yeah so you do have to be
very calm and methodical about what you
do they also do have a they have a
helicopter one right which is just a
cylinder and you sit in the back six of
you right like just like you're in a
helicopter and it drops and then it
rolls over okay and so you're sitting
across from somebody and as it hits and
rolls the guys across from you they go
underwater first and you have more time
to catch your breath and then you go
under and then you're trying to get out
windows and doors and but you have to
use the bench to get out and and and
it's it's a it's a it's very stressful
and then you know somebody panics out of
the six and you kicks you in the face
with there so you're now you're
panicking and now you're flailing so
there yeah it's high stress stuff and it
is a weeding out process it's like yeah
I was gonna say if I had those like
skill sets that you're trained for and
that you develop I don't care if like
comedy and acting was my dream or
anything I would I would need to worm
that into every conversation in every
action like that would be like if I
could do that
I would want to make sure the whole
world at all times knew that I had that
yeah on a plane you know if this thing
flips over so when you're following your
breathing at night we need to follow the
bubbles do you have to put your hands so
you can feel them because you can't see
them no I don't recall that ever being
some they taught us but that's a great
idea
actually to be honest with you know on
that one you refer more to your to your
points okay points of contact because
when you're in the helicopter your point
of contacts to the bench yeah that
you're sitting on what's the ejection
like that with ejection seat they
actually have an ejection seat on rails
so it's about a one-story rail and you
know it's it's it's as advertised you
say Jack 3 times eject eject eject and
on the third
you pull and it launches you up this
rail and you wrong you feel the
compression and the and it gets you
ready for it
obviously you can't eject out of a real
plane right so they have the ejection
seat tjak tjak tjak you have to say it
three times three times because you know
look if on the third time you it gives
you one it's a preparatory order so if
you're in a plane you got to get front
seat and a back seat guy and the pilot
because the pilots the only one who can
make that call really he's like eject
eject eject that it's a preparatory and
letting you know [ __ ] I'm about to be
launched out of a plane that's going 400
miles an hour that way and I'm about to
go 200 miles an hour that way so I'm
about to knock some cavities out of
teeth it really does Wow the LA g-forces
are so bad people people who have
ejected come back about an inch shorter
than when they started flying yeah it
really does mess with you so there's not
it's not a cool thing to eject you know
so yeah you checked and you'll just be
in a plane crash
right exactly you're you're likely back
being in a plane crash but when you when
you hear that 30 checked you know you're
about to ride the ride the lightning let
me ask you I've always wanted this to
when you when you're ejected out of a
plane yeah how did like obviously when
there's yelling you eject you have to
put your hands a certain way so your arm
doesn't get ripped off - yes how do your
legs and your feet not get caught on
something as you're going out that's a
great point
they actually have hooks on you you hook
into your flight suit right and when you
pull that ejection seat okay
those those cords go and everything it
pulls your legs in and so everything
gets tucked in tight to the seat and
then show you're gone and the [ __ ]
top of the canopy comes off the plane in
a nanosecond that's amazing to me how
like you of course all rest in peace
goose that's amazing to me that that
that can happen you can get sucked in
and it's in a second yeah and they did a
good job in that particular movie of
explaining why because normally if you
are flying and you hit that ejection
seat you're going you know hundreds of
miles an hour that canopy is gonna it's
gone sure but if you're in a flat spin
you're going down like this but it's
spinning like this and so there's like
like drafting you know how guys get on
bicycles and ride behind a semi isn't
like quarks wheel down yeah so it's it's
no wind resistance so when when they hit
that e-jet when they hit the ejection
seat in a flat
spent the canopy just kind of hovers
above the aircraft it doesn't rip away
Wow because you're kind of it's a rock
yeah straight down and so there's
obviously a little drafting and so when
they did that and ejected he went into
the canopy that's based on a real it is
incident that happened so how they fixed
that had they done something I've done
that now where the canopy doesn't just
eject out it goes back so when you do
the how does it not think as a stupid
question when you're getting ejected
like I've always been afraid what if it
knocked you into the tail of the plane
or what you know I mean that's why the
the ejection seat has enough juice to it
has the Rockets it will send you it
gives you enough clearance it launches
you into the sky and now oh there's
Rockets under it yes I wondered what
actually made it guy I mean I couldn't
just be a spring I'm like how does that
I never happened by mistake yeah yeah a
g4 spring yeah because you actually when
you get into the aircraft you turn on
the ejection seat you do yeah so you arm
the ejection seat so when you're flying
there are there times obviously if
you're gonna crash you feel like
spiraling out of control but is there a
time when you're flying where there's a
missile something's been fired at your
your plane where you will actually go we
have enough time to eject it which
there's no way to avoid this will they
actually avoid being strikes like that
or you can no I look it's never happened
to me but the pilots that I've talked to
and any pilot generally speaking you're
in charge of your aircraft until you
can't be in charge of your aircraft
meaning there's never going to be a time
when you know if a missiles coming at
you you're never gonna go we're out of
here you're gonna do everything you can
to avoid okay and you're gonna you're
gonna try to fight that missile meaning
you're gonna try to dogfight you're
gonna try to evade it you're gonna put
out countermeasures you're never out of
the fight until you're out of the fight
meaning your aircraft is no longer
flyable have you been in a Harrier jet
no but I have many friends that were
Harry Potter they seem really
fascinating too because they can just
kind of stop and hover and then take off
I mean there's your five later five
physics you know I look it's when the
thrust is underneath you it's in a
fixed-wing aircraft it's bad I think
it's like standing on top of a ball
right right cuz that's how unstable
trying to balance it right now if the
thrust is above you like a helicopter
you have more stability and and it's
just physics it doesn't seem right you
know do you think
fly you have air going over your wings
that's what keeps you a live let's keep
you aloft didn't they use alien
technology I'm sure it is Rob going to
minutes before you go there was that the
only thing that convinces me of UFOs
sometimes is when pilots are confused by
what they're seeing cuz you guys
understand so much about how to fly and
how it worked and there was that one
released where these two pilots are
flying and they're like what did you see
that it did that fight I didn't see that
but I've heard so many accounts of
pilots not being able to identify what
they're seeing and I trust them I don't
think they're crazy pilots it you have
to realize how hard it would be to come
out and say I saw something I can't
identify what do you think it's do you
think it's more likely alien or do you
think it's more likely government things
that people don't have clearance for
that probably I think I'm away I always
try to find the most real explanation
because you know yeah conspiracies are
out there I don't buy into a lot of them
but I do think there is a lot of
experimental aircraft out there that of
course we don't know anything about
I mean look they had the the Blackbird
the SR 7071
that was 1965 technology that they
finally retired in 1991 what is that 30
years yeah you know and for a long time
we didn't even know it existed but it
could fly 3,000 miles an hour at 70 you
know it could fly over Russia before
Russia even had a chance to respond to
it mm-hmm
so we had this that's 65 technology what
do you think we got now right do you
think we have things now though the mic
thing is like you think we have things
now like that's them tracking something
that they see do you think we have
things now that a pilot wouldn't
recognize as a military aircraft even if
it's yeah like II wouldn't recognize the
way it moved yeah I think I think that's
I think that's quite possible I think
yeah I think there's I think there is
unexplainable phenomena that happens but
I don't know what it is but I do you
think that if a pile is tracking to go
what the hell is that thing the chances
are it's not something the military may
get a pilot would least understand the
movement of it right yeah yeah when you
hear about things that defy the laws of
physics that's when it gets into a weird
place where you're like what god I don't
know what that isn't do we have the
technology to defy physics I don't know
and then they don't worry about it take
your green bag
yell about